you need to be literate in ai and if i
narrow it to
the area i'm working in today literate
in natural language
what that means is
typically you don't need researchers
uh you
um
a lot
of what you need to know about the
language model
is
at the level of
common sense
uh maybe the level of a data scientist
that can work with data
understand it play with it and and
experiment with it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to a very special
episode with professor yuav shuam one of
the world's leading experts in computer
science and today specifically natural
language processing with ai 21 labs
javascrime is a professor i'm a readers
of computer science at stanford
university a leading ai expert professor
sharm is fellow of aai
acm and the game theory society
among his awards are the
ijcai research excellence award the aaai
acm allen newell award and the acm
sigai autonomous agents research award
his online game theory course has been
watched by close to a million people and
professor sham has founded several ai
companies including trading dynamics
acquired by ariba the time going timeful
both acquired by google and ai21 labs
professor sham also chairs the ai index
initiative which tracks global ai
activity and progress and we code a
non-profit initiative to train high
quality programmers from disadvantaged
populations thank you yuav i'm very
excited to share this episode
you have i'm trying to make sense of
this world that we're in
co-founder of aa21 labs you're both a
research leading research r d
a vehicle at the same time you're also
building tools for developers like the
developer platform but you're also
building a products for and for
enterprises and businesses and so you're
taking the most advanced cutting edge
natural language processing technologies
and you're bringing them to real world
and this is not a trivial idea because
we're still figuring out
what are we doing with nlp and how is
this going to integrate into our
everyday life so tell me a little bit
about the founding of aa21 labs
and and what sort of brought you into
this world
so ai-21 labs is an unusual company in a
number of respects
and one of them is the real reason we
started the company
we started the company
not because it was one particular
problem we wanted to solve
but because where we saw ai in the
historical perspective
if you go to a website called ai
index.org
this is a project that i started at
stanford about five years ago and it
puts out annual reports about the state
of ai both technological progress but
also just quantity of activity whether
it's the number of students taking
classes or attendance and conferences or
vc money or what have you and all these
um all of those graphs are u-shaped back
in the 80s ai was very very popular
that back in the 90s you weren't allowed
to admit you were doing ai and now
the ai winter
and
now my plumber is doing ai but it's
different very different kind of ai
back in the 80s it was all about
symbolic systems how to represent
knowledge how to draw inferences
sometimes in logic sometimes not
um
there was sometimes a probabilistic
component
but machine learning was always there as
an intellectual activity but didn't play
a key role certainly not in any of the
deployed systems
and wasn't as you know people spoke
about expert systems
it uh wasn't as
bad as some people think but it
certainly over promised and therefore we
entered what was called the ai winter
now the pendulum is swung back
everybody's doing ai which is very
different now it's all about statistics
specifically under the
heading of machine learning and these
days even more specifically deep
learning
and um it's amazing
what we can do now with machine learning
is something that honestly i think a few
of us imagined we could do um
and
the methods have evolved but mostly
we now have
data at scales that
are again hard were hard to imagine
and we have a compute power that again
is just infinite and now you can do
panel recognition
object classification
of all kinds um
incredibly reliably
and you saw the impact in
machine vision first
and there pattern recognition object
recognition such a
a clear
present and important problem
that it was natural to tackle it and you
saw that
there were advances that were dramatic
people speak about imagenet the
collection of
you know now many thousands of photos
where you can suddenly label the photos
or cluster them and so on
you didn't see
that dramatic
impact in language
until about five years ago
and the problem is that you don't have
the analog of object recognition in
language when you think about it
vision is easy quote-unquote to
recognize
that this is a bottle it doesn't really
matter what this pixel over here on the
left is
but there's nothing local and simple in
language i sometimes say that vision
machine vision is a lens into the human
eye
and language is a lens into the human
mind
because there's no thought as
complicated
as you'd like that you can't express in
language but that means it's also much
harder for computers to make sense of
the language but then we saw the needles
start to move because of the particular
brand of neural nets called transformers
as is well known
and then suddenly you saw the needle
move a lot of the academic benchmarks
that kind of puttered along for a while
suddenly
the computer's
approach sometimes exceeded
human level performance
but the truth is that it's a little bit
of
an illusion
um
the the these so-called language models
are incredibly powerful and we'll speak
about them they do amazing things they
do enable things that
are amazing
but they're also limited
um
and um
if you go to a popular language model
for example gpt 3
or our own jurassic one
and you ask it to complete sentences or
to answer questions they'll often do
amazingly well
uh for example surprisingly you ask it
to
add two-digit numbers
and they'll give you the right answer
you'll ask it whether in mathematical
notation or in words
uh how much is 11 plus 12 or you you
could even say
i had 11 apples and i bought 12 apples
how many apples do i have and by and
large you'll get the right answer
you'll ask it to add four digit numbers
you'll get an equally confident answer
that is total
nonsense because these models really
don't understand edition they memorize
many of the examples the training data
they did some amount of generalization
but certainly
don't understand arithmetic
and
we have this amazing intervention
we haven't announced it yet but um
how to do addition we call it the
calculator
um
and so um
so so really you know this you know the
60s hp gave us a calculator that does a
job well
why try to reinvent a wheel and and come
up with a crooked one so mathematics is
a simple example of reasoning that isn't
natural for neural net
uh to engage in
um
ask it to do other sorts of reasoning
temporaries and spatial reasoning
you'll do some amount of it but not
robustly
another problem is those language models
understand so remember language models
the the the term is a little misleading
because you initially might think it's a
model that learns the rules of language
grammar and syntax and so on and it does
that but if it learns much much more it
learns about the world as described by
the text on which it was trained
as you ask that what is the capital of
france you get the right answer
you'll ask it who is the president of
the united states he'll tell you donald
trump
because at the time of the training that
was the case
uh
you might ask donald trump and i'll give
you the same answer but most people
would not
and so
it doesn't have access to
current information it certainly doesn't
have access to proprietary private data
and we and and we know how to access
those things
and so we
we founded the company based on the
previous which was we still believe in
that language
language models are necessary but not
sufficient
we
are
can use these language models to do a
lot of work but we need to augment them
with symbolic reasoning and access to
real-time data and so on so that's the
reason we started the company so we're
talking about a lot of these
transformational ideas that we've had
over the last five years we've had these
models exceed benchmarks and we
understand that it's not necessarily
sufficient and and we obviously have the
recent uh the recent noise about
sanctions etc
where i'm you know if i'm looking at a
21 labs you've positioned the company at
the intersection of research which
you're what you're talking about you're
you're advancing the the
state-of-the-art models uh whether it be
foundational models or specific use
cases but you're also creating offerings
for the world so tell me a little bit
about
balancing those two as a company and
then we'll dive deeper into the the
research oriented aspects
so i started by saying that we're an
unusual company and one
in what one respect is the reason we
started the company i discussed that
another is what you're discussing we we
decided early on and i should say who's
we are i started with my
partner oy goshen
uh and uh very shortly afterwards i'm
not sure i joined as a as a co-founder
not as just as an investor
and
we were
we did not want to just create a
research lab
nothing wrong with that but we really
wanted to create a large business so the
question is what
products or services we wanted to build
that relate to
this deep technology that we were
contemplating
and
here honestly in an ironic
way we were limited
because we looked at many applications
there's text everywhere we looked at
legal tech at ediscovery we looked at
healthcare electronic patient records we
looked at construction tech
mega projects were just text all day uh
we looked at enterprise application we
even had a prototype running the
enterprise that implemented a playbook
for sales teams
that rather than have a sales uh
a a playbook that perhaps is
read once by a incoming
uh sales executive if that and never
again uh imagine
a playbook that's live that's reading
your email with you give you contextual
advice based on the text
and what we realized pretty quickly was
that
all of these could be wonderful
businesses
but they don't make enough contact with
the types of innovation that we wanted
to bring to bear so in an ironic way to
limit us to application that required
this deep technology and so our mission
is to change how we produce and consume
information
and
specifically how we write and how we
read
because when we think about it the way
we write today is the way a product
manager at microsoft decided in 1980 and
that's true even if you're writing in
gdocs or gmail
you have you have advances you have
collaboration you have spell checking
you have auto complete but the
fundamental experience hasn't changed
and we think about reading uh we're
executing on the vision of uh you know
from you know of guttenberg from the
15th century with a printing press
somebody put a piece of paper or a
screen and we look at it
and we think that both of these
experiences which are intertwined by the
way
um can be radically rethought if you
take ai as a basic building block
and turn the machine
into
a thought partner in this creative
process
and so that's our mission
and which means that
we uh
we do we we started out by building our
own applications a year and a half ago
we uh
we released our first product called
we're tuned which focuses purely on the
writing side
and
honestly it's a
first step of a much longer road the
tail end of which looks like total
science fiction
uh except it'll all be done in two years
um
but even this first step
was fairly transformational to speak
about word tune because it's very
different from other writing assistants
uh that are out there
i want to delay for a second on what he
just said
the long tail will look like science
fiction yet we're talking about a prism
of two years this is a really
foundational idea that i'm trying to
understand here we have these remarkable
advancements that are progressing so
quickly and we're breaking the
benchmarks on almost a weekly basis at
this point
how is the world going to respond or
going to be impacted
by for example the tale of of word tune
the science fiction so to speak do you
how do you experience or consciously
think about
the way that teams around the world are
going to experience nlp enterprises are
going to to bring nlp into their work so
nlp is a very broad umbrella really
language is an interface
to everything to the way
between people but also
a new way to interact with machines
and so when we speak about the impact
it's very broad discussion
if i limit a discussion of how it'll
impact how we write for example just to
make it narrower
um
maybe uh i can best explain it by an
analogy
if you're writing a book
or an article in a
prestigious magazine
uh you used to have a copy editor i
don't know if the people still have it
because machines do it well spell
checking grammar correction
that's commodity and you know you can do
it but you also have an editor
and the editor is really a thought
partner they look at it and their
experiences say listen
this part doesn't capture what you have
in mind
or
these two paragraphs don't cohere or
this whole section isn't really adding
to the story
this editor doesn't replace you
but it makes
you a better version of yourself and i
think that's what we'll see in writing
assistance
a really a thought partner in the
writing process and that's just one case
writing
right and obviously we have
what you mentioned in the beginning was
this idea that
these foundational models
understand the information that we have
they at least pertaining to the time
that they were trained
in pretty significant ways whether it
and these can come about in
conversational iii these can come about
in contextual learning or or within a
organization's information so we'll see
some transformative uh solutions over
there i'm sure and and i'm sure that a21
labs will have a piece of that as well
going back to jurassic one foundation
models and where we're at today in in
2022 breaking the boundaries talk to me
a little bit about symbolic reasoning as
as a as an idea where of of
in hybrid with deep learning to advance
the boundaries of foundation models um
so first of all jurassic world the the
model we built um you know more than a
year ago
um
is is not neurosymbolic it's purely a
neural system
uh
very much inspired by gpd3 we were
enthusiastic users of gpg3 were still
big fans of
of open ai
but for a variety of reasons we felt we
we needed to um to have our own model
and so it's just a similar sort of model
so-called auto-regressive left-to-right
model uh it has some important
differences but it didn't break the mold
in fundamental ways
uh it's just a very good workhorse
um it's still the only large model that
by large i mean more than 100 billion
parameters that's available to third
parties to
to to work with
um
but um it was clear to us that that's a
basic workhorse a necessary not
sufficient condition
and
so there's a variety of innovations in
purely neural approaches and they're
important and we can speak about them uh
you know insights about
tweaking the architecture about training
longer uh about various attention
mechanism uh all very important
um
also um ways of interfacing these models
through
prompt engineering prompt tuning and
other methods that
try to coax out of this
huge model
information that
is there
but
wouldn't come out if you didn't code
the model into revealing it
um
but
as i said at the beginning
we believe all of that is necessary but
not sufficient because there are certain
things that these neural models are not
good for they're not optimized for
maybe
if you
let the neural net
train
for
years
and you know multiply the size by
10 entertaining time by a hundred
and spend not
30 million dollars to train them but you
know
one billion dollars
they'll generalize more and they'll
learn all kinds of stuff that i'm sure
will be interesting
it's not at all clear that they'll learn
mathematics as we know it
um
but we know how to do mathematics
and so
it's seems so obvious to us
that we should have the best of both
worlds have the statistical entrance
and statistical
access to world knowledge i don't want
to use the term understanding that's a
loaded term
but
a
a a good way
to get that statistical
knowledge textual and also non-textual
knowledge of the world
and augment it
with uh structured knowledge real-time
information and optimize reasoning that
optimize for certain islands of
knowledge and that was jurassic x is
which we developed a couple months ago
phenomenal
so
if you're looking at a 21 labs
as a
as an entrance right now you're
mentioning that jurassic one is still
one of the only use cases for third
parties to be able to interact with
these large models
where are we headed in terms of these
foundation models very pragmatically in
terms of applications for for businesses
and enterprises so we have these large
models we know how expensive they are to
train we know that the the
how
difficult it is for it's not that that
any research team and any organization
can go ahead and train these models and
create them
is this something that we're expecting
to have the integration of in the next
couple years is do you expect that every
small business will have access to
create their own applications or to use
sort of these black box applications by
companies like a21 labs how do you see
the sort of the near future in terms of
our use cases with these word models
these language models
so the short answer is yes
these
language models
or foundation models if you want to
enlarge it to things that are not purely
linguistic
um
uh
are becoming
much more generally available
they will become more so
models such as jurassic one
a year from now
will be commodity
this is an area where you need to run to
stay in place
and so
the innovation will continue at a fast
pace
and
increasingly
people small business as large
businesses
will incorporate them in
all their offerings and in my opinion
because language is such a fundamental
modality of interface
there's a question
of
who will who will trade these models
as they become increasingly expensive
will it be a small and smaller set of
organizations
there's also another
issue which is i think even more
fundamental
is that these are early days
people don't really know how to work
with these models
what they're good for and how best to
use them
and
really um
what you have right now is is akin to
henry ford
uh announcing his great invention uh an
engine and sending an engine to people
and say go have fun
they're quite removed from the value
proposition
that an actual user developer or
organization
can relate to
and so i think what you'll see two
things you'll see these models get not
only more sophisticated but also
enveloped in layers that make it much
closer to the application and you'll see
the market get educated
increasingly i think we were facing
probably on the order of two years
before there's more maturity both inside
the providers and consumers of nlp
technology
so i'm taking us two years into the
future right now and i'm looking at the
creator economy as almost a metaphor for
the creation of of language right i mean
i think it it's it suits perfectly here
i'm looking two years down the line when
models like jurassic one are
commoditized and and general access
makes it easy for anybody to create
content uh change content analyze
content
what should be be doing now
so that in two years down the line we
can use these effectively and
responsibly i'm thinking even general
things like the way that we communicate
information news articles uh public
knowledge what is truth if a lot of
people disseminate information that is
semi-truth right how do you even think
as a sort of as a cutting edge
researcher here who's pushing the
boundaries and part of this running
how are you thinking through some of
these some of these questions i think
there are several sort of questions
folded into your
question
um
you have to realize that
i'm sure you do
that
um that um
you can't easily generate content with
current models
you can
generate seemingly cogent and useful
stuff
if you go and you know
prompt a model you'll get surprisingly
relevant things
and
a bunch of garbage
i know our organization a publisher a
very big publisher who's been using
um
a large language model
with the thought of
increasing the efficiency because they
create a lot of content so perhaps they
can automate some of it and what they
found
all the savings they've had in the
generation of the content
is washed away by the need to prune
analyze and vet the output of those
because
they are they hallucinate they don't
make sense they contradict themselves
and all of that
and so i think we have a way to go
uh and it's not only
in creating better language models
uh understanding that language model is
a general facility on top of which
uh you need to add a lot
so um
in our application
um
you know
whether it's
you know we're tuned or watching read or
we now have a a very fun
uh
uh thing that doesn't even have a name
but if you can find it it allows you to
consume video um
more efficiently and um
in all of those cases the language model
was a basis
essential
but
definitely less than half of the work it
took
to actually provide
you know a writer's writing assistant a
reading assistant or a video skimmer and
so
we have a lot of work to do and it's not
all about language models there are
there's a good
foundation model that percy liang and
his many colleagues coined is not a bad
term because it's foundation
but a house needs more than a foundation
foundation models are a good term
because they do
provide
foundations for many applications that
are based on land i'll focus on language
on language
but
when you build a house a foundation is
central
but it's only part of the house
and
to 100 basic engine with its foundation
and turn into a useful
product or facility or what
uh takes a lot more work and
that's something that i think perhaps
some people don't realize because it's
easy to create fun demos
uh we we just recently put out
uh something called ask ruth bader
ginsburg
ask rpg and um
it's
it's i it it didn't push technology in
interesting ways we uh fine-tuned our
model really not exactly fine-tuned but
we
we trade the model uh so that it could
uh mimic the style and content of what
the late judge would would have said in
response to kind of legal questions
um
and um and it's fun but our purpose for
putting it out was not
to
you know
to tell the public look how great ai is
that's part of it but part of it is
you know
buy everywhere
it does wonderful things and it's
limited
and so
yeah that's that's the foundation
i i i i looked into it and that was a
pretty awesome i have to say and i was
constantly thinking in my head wow
people's brains are being
mine are being blown away right now
because this is one of the first use
cases that we see this interacting into
our daily life in in a really meaningful
way and you're right i mean there is a
lot of noise out there and a lot of
conversation around what this means and
obviously the whole conversation of of
saint chance uh et cetera and uh and and
i saw also uh something we posted on
linkedin recently about this and i think
it was your quote i hope i'm not
misquoting you for somebody else but i
think in one of the articles about rbg's
um demo that you've had you said i i
don't want people to be disappointed by
the underperformance of current ai and i
don't want them to monger fear and i
think that's a it's a pretty powerful
idea which is really explaining what
what you're saying here is that we have
to understand really where we are what's
limited but but my my issue is you have
is that you know the public doesn't
really understand what's happening right
i'm barely able to keep up with the
academic research and i barely
understand myself the limitations and
the potential of what we have
so if i'm looking now at how i mean
businesses around the world are going to
run to want to implement a lot of these
tools because it'll give an edge in
whatever we do so how so what what
education do we need to provide and at
what layers do you think for
organizations around the world in two
years time to be able to use to use
these these models effectively into our
own use cases do we need new positions
within organizations do we need every
organization to have researchers on
board or specific pms dedicated for this
how do we integrate the world into a new
place where now
these language models are are being able
to be integrated into our everyday life
it'll vary
among organizations of course both in
terms of their sophistication and their
mission and their resources
but
just as
you know personal computers
started to
infiltrate
industry
uh it was clear that you needed to be
literate in computing you need to be
literate in ai and if i narrow it to the
area i'm working in today literate in
natural language
what that means is
typically you don't need researchers
you um
a lot
of
what you need to know about the language
model
is
at the level of
common sense
maybe the level of a data scientist that
can work with data
understand it play with it and and
experiment with it
and
uh my advice to
so we when we put out jurassic we had 10
000 developers signed up
uh it it honestly it was overwhelming um
so you know we don't have time to speak
with all of them on a kind of personal
basis
but when we do
um
my advice is first of all dip your toes
in the water
there's no substitute to experience dip
your toes in the water and second
uh think about the simplest use case in
your business your organization where
you have an intuition it may not be the
highest value that's not important right
now but with the match
with uh
language is obvious
and earn the side of the simplest
application don't necessarily rush to
create a chatbot chestnuts are hard uh
they don't really well
um i don't want to dis my colleague but
they
don't they don't work um
why if your dad here heard me say this
uh we have a problem
um
delicious may not know that your dad is
one of the foremost uh researchers in ai
and runs the
gruel research activity in israel is an
amazing guy um
but but anyway um
the um
um
take a simple um
for example
um we had
uh i won't mention even the industry but
we had a company
that had not a chat bot but they had a
simple dialogue question answering uh to
their offering to to
to users it was kind of brittle because
they had a set of questions
and
can't answers and the chance that a
question would match exactly
um
the uh one of the
you know the art you know their bank of
questions was very low
and
but that really lends itself to uh
to language to diversify the question
and understand which question is perhaps
closest
and diversified the answers
and
and that's an example of a relatively
simple application that's well within
the reach
of current technology and that doesn't
call for
a huge investment of resources or deep
knowledge of natural language
so
find a
good problem not the most complicated
one and start experimenting
so you have you're a
an innovator and a researcher
what are you most excited about right
now in natural language
whether it's something that we have
something that we're working towards
when before you go to sleep and you're
thinking to yourself wow
what crazy world we're in what are you
most excited about
for today or for the future to be honest
every day i go into the office i'm blown
away
because
people are doing such creative things
and
every day i'm blown away by uh something
that they're doing that i would not have
thought of
and so
it's not one thing
um
it's um
it's
um the the possibilities are so exciting
um
you know we're focused on on on a
particular mission of helping you right
and if we read
and
and the idea that i could go
jot down
some of my ideas
and
then the system will help me turn them
into a whole narrative
um i find that exciting because
i pride myself on how i express myself
and yet
you see this i'll tell you a story um so
one of my hobbies is wine
and
uh the
the one of the best known critics of the
wine critics in the world uh and the the
the the best known british critic is
james robinson
and she has this newsletter
and what they have is an annual short
story competition
and
so we had this it wasn't even a
product it was a
such a fun demo
um
so you know gpd3 the the initial demos
were
you know write the first paragraph
they'll complete the whole story but of
course it would invariably go and
meander and you know who knows where it
goes
and so we said rather than extrapolate
from a a starting point
why don't you give it the beginning and
the end and have it interpolate
uh between them
uh and uh with the thought was it'll
give us more of a direction of where to
go and maybe we'll meet our list uh the
system was called haim uh and by the way
it invented its own name
uh we gave it the the prompt i'm a
language generation system my name is
and one decision was hein
um
and um
and uh so we chose the name haim of
course we retrofitted an acronym i think
it was
what was it i think it was a halfway
adequate interpolation machine but
then the natural
next step was to build heimke
with kn points rather than best
beginning at the end
build a whole bunch of
write a bunch of sentences so that's
what i did i wrote i think six sentences
about wine
and out came a whole story and the
sister was interactive he said i didn't
like this try again i'll make it short
and make it longer after a few tweaks
like this there was a story it was kind
of fun story and i sent a turn she
published it
and
you know that's so much fun to do but
that wasn't the product
we're not yet at the stage where you can
do this really in real life
but when you think about the
possibilities here
it's just
it's it's so fun
so so you have i i can honestly i am i'm
feeling your excitement even even
through this uh this remote podcast but
are you considering yourself more of a a
researcher and a you know a
mathematician computer scientist a
creative entrepreneur i mean who who
really is you have shum you know you've
been a professor emeritus at stanford
for dozens of years you've you've been a
you know pushing the boundaries of
technology and research
pretty much your whole life yet i'm
hearing you talk with so much excitement
and joy about the applications
of what some of these inventions are
doing so how do you sort of
see yourself in this world
um
well it's not like they're mutually
exclusive right um the nice thing is we
have this luxury
of
so we like to build stuff you know um
the difference between you know
being a scientist and being creator a
science scientist tries to understand
god a creator is god
and um
and so
you're trying to to do both
um it's a lot of fun to create it's
addictive once you've done it you know
there's no going back um it's a matter
of personal taste i have one of my best
friends is
you know maybe israel's tough
mathematician
and
he loves proving theorems
um and he's he's amazing at it
um
i'm maybe because i'm not as amazing at
it uh i resorted to being a creator so
it's both but
um but it's creation based on deep
principle deep mathematics so the
combination appeals to me
yeah thank you so much and not just for
this last uh 40 minutes but for your
work in general i've been enjoying so
much following the different things that
you've been putting out there both as a
professor and researcher but also as an
entrepreneur ai21 labs is one of the
most
important companies today pushing the
boundaries of nlp which is undoubtedly
revolutionizing the world i think in
ways that very few
around the world still understand and i
i honestly can't wait to see in two
years time what what will be of word
tune or any other product that ai 21
labs does and and how the world is going
to respond to all of this and i think
we've raised some interesting questions
here we've only touched the surface on
some of them and and we're i'm going to
be thinking about them for much longer
over these next two years and i i really
appreciate your time and energy well
we're talking in two years 100
thank you very very much
[Music]